came out earlier this year
Eric tey Mike McCarty the expansion pack
the old blood came out last night old
hunters the old hunters Wolfenstein
dammit Wolfenstein get out of my brain
game was pretty good but we're not here
to talk about that talk about the
hard-on of God for old yharnam you've
been playing it this last night
the expansion pack I've been playing it
for longer than that I'll have you I was
playing it since last night over there
yeah he's been at it for like a week now
what gets you in a minute okay Mike
Marty yeah Eric you tell me about these
hunters what's going on uh so basically
you're kind of like traveling in a way
back or like not back but you're going
into the hunters nightmare okay so still
in yharnam it's still in the same it's
yeah it's kind of still in yharnam but
it's all like slightly different it's
all like I think to use Miguel's word
the reviewers word it's like Doh if I'd
like here you go you can see it here
it's all like oh kind of just I guess
the desert it turned into a desert
whatever um but so you see that I'm
fighting a hunter there and basically
what's happened is a lot of these
hunters that are in the hunters
nightmare are just super bloodthirsty
and so they just kill anything on sight
and so she's way more aggressive then
yeah so you had to deal with a bunch
more of them that you didn't have to in
the original game as well as other
monsters
well yeah it's it's kind of more
blood-borne it's it's cool I like it
there's like a bunch of new weapons yeah
what's in it because I think originally
wasn't this this is actually a makeup of
two different DLC packs that and they
sort of decided all actually we're gonna
bundle these together out a bit more
content and make it a yeah so there is
not gonna be another expansion this is
like the only one for was born and I
think it's like over twelve primary like
right-handed weapons and then there's I
think five like secondary weapons which
are like you know your gun there's a
Gatling gun there's a church cannon
that's one of the new weapons of blood
letter there's a good variety in these
because obviously one of the important
things about these
games is that the weapons do like change
the sort of you know cadence and rhythm
of combat yeah there's definitely a wide
variety of weapons you know to suit
different players needs if they want
agility or strength there's a little bit
of more arcane stuff not too much but a
little bit and that's kind of what
blood-borne is about because it's not so
in-depth in terms of like Dark Soul
stats you know like that that was a big
thing where you know you could really
tweak a build you can kind of do it here
but not really it's the weapons that
really change what cuz that thing yeah
it's so the Amidala arm there is kind of
like those aliens you saw it but it's
kind of like a little piece of it so
it's a yeah interesting kind of like
mace type thing that also has like a
like like a tentacle type thing that's
the saw that they had in that people
that were sort of pausing on the trailer
as well yeah and new outfits as well oh
yeah there's a like four or five sets of
new armor there could be more I haven't
like found all the secrets I think
that's one of the cool things about
blood-borne is that even though I beat
it there's all this stuff I'm still
finding and still trying to find and
yeah so cool stuff though excellent Mike
what are you thinking of it I got to the
first boss and died on my second try and
I got semi-closed when I was talking to
tell you I know like I don't want to
spoil anything about any bosses but yeah
it's definitely more the same which I
was completely looking for is looking
for an excuse to get back into it after
a New Game+ but I took so long to you
have to beat I don't know have where's
that like you have to be da bikkar
Emilia this one of these bosses kind of
like early game bosses in order to get
to it and I was oh why oh so long on her
that I by the time I got to the
expansion last night I was just I was
exhausted but I got to the first boss
and I definitely it's like he said like
you see way more hunters which are
always pretty they're divided so
formidable yeah and it's very weird
because so I'm so used to everything
from the first game I played through it
to new game plusses and then now that
really yeah now that I have new a new
like area to explore it's a little more
back to how I felt when I first played
blood-borne in the first place like just
way more unwelcoming I don't know what's
around the next corner it's kind of
unsettling but in a great way so I you
know never played any of the old
a bunch of people here who've got like
you know lots of love for Dark Souls
demon souls and then played a bunch of
this as well i never completed
blood-borne but I adored us like really
had a great time with it is there
anything in this for me or is this very
much for people who have completed
blood-borne earlier near I would say
this is mainly for people who've
completed blood-borne I think it's the
first boss I actually have been think
the first boss here is one of the more
challenging bosses in like blood-borne
itself because there are a few bosses I
could see having as much trouble within
the main game but you could jump into it
if you wanted to if you haven't been the
game I would definitely recommend
beating the game first and maybe
starting a new one or just doing it a
new game+ although the latter is gonna
be a little harder I think and how much
of how much you think is in this one say
like in terms of you know its powers
yeah kind of yeah every knife getting
got word about it but like yeah it's
been like eight months or whatever since
blood one came out it was back in March
now so yeah like is there enough here to
get you going for another couple of
weeks or what was a pretty sure weeks is
kind of a kind of a stretch I would say
I mean like if you go and if you play it
slowly maybe like weeks I would say for
me I've hit in the teens I did struggle
with some of the bosses you know some
people may some people may not they do
have like a new system where you can
call on like these co-op AI hunters in
the game that you couldn't do in the
past like them so in the in the original
version the only way you could really
get help was you had to bring your Bell
and hope that somebody I think that was
like 10 levels around you could come and
help you but this time around for maybe
some of the players that you know we're
struggling or something like that they
have a way to do that so but it got me
in the teens in terms of like hours
played and there's always little secrets
that depending on how like much you want
to figure them out like they will add
hours to the gameplay that's what's
getting me back into it right now is
like trying to figure out which weapons
are good there's so many weapons now
like that weapons is part of the
replayability of blood-borne because you
can't level them within one playthrough
you can really only level like one
really solidly to max level and then
it's like well I kind of want try this
other weapon or this other builders yeah
so it's it's up to the player at that
point but yeah i think i think it's it's
pretty solid though i
we're in the old hunters 9 and 10 on
Gainesville calm and before I let you
guys go our gaming your discussions are
ramping up we're getting almost into
December gonna be having some real fun
chats next week weirdoes blood-borne lie
in here I don't love them people aren't
saying it's like the best game that's
coming up but it's certainly up there
right in the top like 10 at least for
some of the best games that have come
out this year yeah I think I'll just go
first but like I think for both of us
personally I think personally for both
of us I think it's within our top 10 for
this year I never played five I don't
know I was actually like messing around
just a little bit this morning and it
might be for me I never played a souls
game
I was always kind of afraid it was
something that looked kind of like a
huge time seeing something that could
frustrate the hell out of me and I just
thought he plays a lot of like goblins
yeah yeah okay I get into grindy games
and stuff like that but like I don't
know what it was about blood one that
drew me to it it just seemed like oh
this is kind of like Dark Souls but like
way faster and more action-oriented and
I just love the combat like you feel
rewarded when you do something really
like amazing the perfect dodge or like
when you wait and learn the moves and
the subtle nuances and you're like okay
he's gonna do this bang shoot you with a
gun I stick my arm through your chest
and you just feel good like when you do
that and that's what blood-borne gave
for me and you know I it was frustrating
at times but I knew why I died like it
was like me I mistake i if I like panic
dodged or like was spamming dodge too
much I would get hit and like yep I
totally deserved that and there's
something about that that kind of game
that just drew me in and probably in my
top 5 is school affair Mike what about
yourself yeah I definitely put in my top
5 I I've been playing it throughout the
year still with New Game+ and kind of
one of those games I've been going back
to throughout the year and like taste
said the combat satisfying it you always
feel like it was your fault it would
unlike the Dark Souls games which a lot
of times can kind of throw these curve
balls at you it always felt like it was
really your you could master it and get
through it and also I think the level
design itself is just unreal between
just finding a new Lantern and a
shortcut is as much a victory almost a
lot of times like maybe not as much to
killing a boss but it's up there cool
gentlemen thank you so much coming on
yeah
Bohr and the old hunters out now if your
blonde friend go pick it up let us know
what you think of it and blog borns
chance at game of the year in the
comment box below